what I want to do in this video is think
about the demand curve for two different
products so this is some laptop that's
on the market and lists let's just say
is the cheapest car that happens to be
on the market this is actually a picture
of a 1985 you go but we're just assuming
it's the cheapest car in the market so
let's just think about their
hypothetical demand curves right now so
once again in the vertical axis we're
going to put price and the horizontal
axis we put quantity quantity and then
over here let me do it for the same
thing so this is price this is price and
this right over here is quantity and
both of them satisfy the law of demand
if the price is really high the quantity
demanded is going to be really low for
the laptop and so it might be right over
there and if the price is low the
quantity demanded is going to increase
so it might the demand curve might look
something like that and it doesn't have
to be a curve or it doesn't have to be a
line it could be a curve it could be
anything like that so that is the
current demand for the laptop so this is
the current current demand all else
equals so we're not talking about
shifting any of those other factors that
we've been talking about in the last few
videos now we could draw a similar
demand curve for this very cheap
automobile if the price is high very few
people are going to want to buy it and
I'm not going to even specify what the
price is but this is a general idea of
the price is higher if you were people
going to buy it if the price is lower
more people are going to want to buy it
so it's demand curve will also have this
shape from the top left to the bottom
right it satisfies the law of demand so
once again that is the current demand
current demand now let's think about how
how the demand for each of these goods
might change depending on changes in
income so we're going to focus on the
income factor the income effect for this
video and see how these two products
might change so let's just assume let's
assume that income in the general
population income in the general
population goes up so for something like
a laptop
Wow if more people
are making more money especially in real
terms they have more money to spend well
at any given price point at any given
price point there's going to be a higher
there's going to be a higher quantity
that's demanded at any given price point
higher quantity demanded at any price
point a higher quantity demanded and so
if income goes up for this laptop the
demand will increase and the way we show
demand increasing is the whole curve
shifts to the right so this right over
here demand increased demand went up
when income went up and that makes
complete sense and if income were to go
down demand would go down because people
would have less money to buy something
like a net laptop and this is the case
for most goods and we call things like
this so when income goes up demand goes
up the whole curve shifts to the right
income goes down demand goes down whole
curve shift to the left we call this a
normal good so this right over here is a
normal normal good now let's think about
what happens with the cheapest car on
the market and let's assume that we are
in a developed country where almost
everyone has some form of a car now what
happens when income goes up so people
have more money but are they going to
spend that money buying the cheapest car
on the market well in most cases if
income goes up generally people say oh I
have a little bit more money now maybe
I'll buy a slightly nicer car so and
maybe in particular the people who were
going to buy this car at any given price
point so at this price point the people
who are going to buy the car
well say wait I can now afford a better
car why should I go you know this is not
safe maybe or not foot safe as the other
cars and and you know I want to impress
my friends from high school and all of
that so something very strange might
happen for this car right for the demand
for this car it actually will decrease
so the whole curve could shift to the
left the whole curve could shift to the
left so income did a very strange thing
for this good because in Krum increasing
made people say hey you know what I
could trade out of this good I could get
a good that I would rather have than
just getting more of this thing right
over here demand went down
and goods like this we call inferior
Goods inferior inferior Goods and the
general way to think about inferior
Goods are the goods that people will
want to not own if they had more money
they would want to buy I guess less
inferior goods or another way to think
about it is if income were to go down if
income were to go down and more people
are budget strapped and they can't
afford the Mercedes Benz or the BMW or
even the mid-sized sedan anymore so if
incomes were to go down and things we
get tighter more people would want this
car more people would have to trade down
to this because they're there they're
strapped they're tightening their their
belts and so you would have the strange
situation where if income goes down
demand would go up for this thing so
income income goes down demand goes up
and remember when we're talking about
demand we're talking about the entire
shifting of the curve at any given price
point the quantity demanded will go up
because this is the or we're assuming
it's the cheapest car on the market so
and likewise if income were to go down
for a normal good it would do what you
expect demand would go down so this is
an inferior good does the opposite of a
normal good and that's when when we're
talking about the income effect this is
important when we're talking about the
income effect and inferior good will do
the opposite of a normal good and that's
because people want to trade out of it
when their income goes up or they don't
want to buy it they want to buy
something nicer and when income goes
down they say oh I have to buy this
thing so let me just you know let me
just do it